well this is it you guys finally the
launch of the radeon rx 6900 xt the last
big launch of 2020 the end
of the ridiculous gauntlet of back to
back to back to back to back cpu and
graphics cards launches over the past
month and a half two months i don't know
how long it's been why are you getting
angry don't get mad
anyway though today we're talking about
the updated answer to the consummate
question
who makes the fastest gaming gpu is it
amd
or is it nvidia we're gonna answer that
today and maybe just maybe
after the video i can finally see a
light at the end of the tunnel i've been
in beckoning me home to a
quiet peaceful place where i can rest
and put all this endless testing and
benchmarks and stock and availability
woes and customers being upset
behind me actually that's not a light at
the end of the tunnel that's actually
just a reflection of the glowing radeon
logo on this
6900 xt it can do rgb now
excellent so guys i have spent as much
time as i had available to spend testing
the radeon rx 6900xt in the past few
days
and while i will be going over
benchmarks that you can jump ahead to
via the timestamps in the description
i want to be upfront that my focus today
is on traditional pc gaming shading and
rasterization performance
with just a touch of ray tracing i
simply did not have time for
productivity performance testing
which should be a consideration for the
6900 xt as well as the rtx 3090 that i'm
comparing it to
that said as i have done a few times
recently i will post some links in the
video's description to other reviews of
this card that are up today
that might fill you in on some of that
performance of course the radeon rx 6900
xt
is probably already sold out by the time
you watch this video but it is intended
to sell for one thousand dollars msrp
another consideration for these recent
launches is the lack of availability of
the graphics cards
and overpricing by resellers and
scalpers which is a
difficult nut to crack as a reviewer i
could go with the current situation and
wildly fluctuating prices and discuss
that or i could rely on what
manufacturers
say the actual retail prices will be of
these cards once they're more widely
available and long story short that is
what i am doing today simply for the
sake of simplicity let's quickly go over
this card and my testing setup though
the rx 6900xt is an all new custom
designed card from amd and the reference
design for the 6900xt
is exactly the same as the 6800xt same
size same three cooling fans
same color scheme same power connectors
and video outs in fact you might not
have noticed but this footage i'm
showing you right now
is the 6800xt not the 6900xt so that's
how you
save time shooting b-roll the 6900xd
also measures 10.5 inches long and is a
2.5 slot card but the only really way to
tell the difference
other than plugging them in and pulling
up gpu-z or something is by
looking at the label on the card it also
still has the backlit
red radeon logo which defaults to red
although as of today amd is finally
releasing the rgb control software to
change that logo to different colors
i did not have time to test that out
today either but even looking at the
specs list the 6900xt and 6800xt are
very similar with the same 300 watt tdp
and 750 watt recommended power supply
the memory is still
16 gigs of gddr6 vram with a data rate
of 16 gigabits per second but the 6900
xt has a fully enabled chip with 80
compute units
and 5120 stream processors versus 72
compute units and 4608 stream processors
on the 6800 xt here you can also see
comparison specs and data for the other
cards i'm testing today
including the 1500 plus rtx 3090. moving
on to my test setup though we're using
my open
amd test bed upgraded to the 5900x 12
core 24 thread cpu
running with auto oc and pbo enabled and
cooled by an nzxt kraken x62 280
millimeter all-in-one cpu cooler the
motherboard is the gigabyte x570 aorus
master and the memory is 16 gigs of
g-skill trident z royal rgb running at
ddr4 3600
cast latency 16. stats for the rest of
the hardware is listed on this slide if
you want to take a closer look
and also smart access memory or sam the
feature that allows the cpu to access
all of the vram from the graphics card
which requires an amd setup with a 5000
series cpu and a 500 series motherboard
is enabled for all of my testing i had
the choice of turning it on or turning
it off and i decided to turn it on
and again that feature allows the cpu to
access all of the vram from the graphics
card
rather than just a 256 megabyte chunk
and it typically results in
anywhere from zero to five percent
performance boost let's move into the
benchmarks and here are the actual clock
speeds i was seeing out of the cards
while in use
amd lists a base and a game clock for
their gpus and while the game clock is
supposed to be the average frequency
under a typical gaming load
i found it was actually underestimated
my card hit 2582 megahertz peak
frequency which is even higher than the
6800 xt hit
although that was just for a quick burst
the average was about 23 30 megahertz
under load
again even higher than the listed 2 250
megahertz boost clock
it does seem like the 6900xt might have
a better bend gpu than the 6800 xt
even if it's just running 5 to 10
megahertz faster on average
and now it's time for the benchmarks
3dmark time spy xtreme is a synthetic
benchmark from 3dmark a directx 12 test
and here the 6900xt is about 11.3
percent slower than the rtx 3090 when
comparing the graphics score while the
rtx 3070 brings up the rear end is 33
percent slower
if you want an idea of how these compare
to last gen gpus the 3070 compares
pretty well to the rtx 2080 ti
the 20 series flagship 3dmark port royal
is next another synthetic from 3dmark
with a focus on ray tracing in a 3d
rendered environment i already knew that
the amd cards were going to suffer here
as nvidia has a hardware lead
and an advantage in ray tracing tests
they've just been doing ray tracing for
longer the 6900xt is 30.5 percent slower
than the rtx 3090 and
can't even keep up with the rtx 3080
although both radeon cards did manage to
beat out the rtx 3070. shadow of the
tomb raider is running in directx 12
mode and at 1080 we have an interesting
result as the 6800xt
edges out the 6900xt and all the rtx
cards
were cpu limited at this resolution but
the 6900 xt did beat the rtx 3090 by
about 3 percent
at 1440p the 6900xt is on top followed
closely by the 6800 xt and both are
about 5
faster than the rtx 3090 which had some
trouble with the one percent lows at 4k
the rtx 3090 comes out on top and at
this resolution cpu limitations are
minimized so we're looking at more of a
direct gpu comparison
great performance overall from the
radeon cards in these first set of tests
though let's see if they can keep it up
here is metro exodus and at 1920x1080
the rtx 3090 is on top with the 6900xt
trailing by 4.6 percent
both radeon gpus showed better
consistency in the one percent lows
however at 1440 we have a similar story
with reduced frame rates of course
and the 3090 still had trouble with the
one percent lows although its average
was still 5.3 percent faster than the
6900 xt
at 4k the 3090 manages to win outright
with 77.3
average frames per second the 6900 xt is
8.5 percent slower here and the 6800 xt
trails by almost 15 percent microsoft
flight simulator 2020 is a beautiful
directx 11 title but still punishes gpus
in terms of achievable frame rates
at 1080 the rtx 3080 takes the win kind
of like a younger sibling besting their
older brother or sister perhaps
inspired by the 6800 xt's similar
performance and shadow of the tomb
raider anyway though the 3080 was 2
faster than the 3090 here while the 6900
xt was 2.75 percent slower at 1440p
the whole field of gpus shifts with the
6900xt jumping into first
and the 3080 dropping to fourth that's a
1.1 percent win for the 6900 xt over the
3090 and the 6800 xt is 5
behind at 4k though again the 3090
surges back to take the lead and average
frame rate and one percent lows the 6900
xt fell behind by 12.3 percent at this
resolution
gta 5 is another title i've benchmarked
way too many times but i still love it
and at 1080 we are cpu capped with all
cards performing within six or seven
frames per second of each other the
consistent stuttering that i saw in my
6800 xt video returned
for the 6900xt so the one percent lows
are not looking good here
again though it continues at 1440 but
effectively will disappear when we get
to 4k
at 1440 the 6900x is just 2 percent
slower than the 3090 on average but the
stutters in the test were noticeable
still meanwhile at 4k
even though the overall frame rate was
lower those frame spikes disappeared or
at least
calmed down a lot the 6900 xt is still
almost 18
behind the rtx 3090 at this resolution
though battlefield 5 is also running in
directx 12 mode and at 1080 the 6900 xt
shoots the gap
between the rtx 3080 and rtx 3090
unfortunately it's still about 10
behind in one percent low performance
but the cpu factors in heavily at this
resolution
in the 1440 race the 6800 xt again
shows that big navi is all about that
1440p resolution and although again
the one percent lows are weak point
seven and seven point four percent wins
for the 6900 and 6800 xt respectively
over the rtx 3090 is nothing to sneeze
at
at 4k the rtx 3090 establishes dominance
yet again the 6900 xt is 2.9 percent
slower and the 6800 xt
is 6 percent slower death stranding is
next using directx 12 and running at the
very high preset
at 1920x1080 the xt just
barely edges out the rtx 3070 by less
than a frame or
0.3 percent so you could just call it a
tie and i would say that the 6800 xt
keeps up well here too at 1440 the rtx
3090 reclaims the lead by
almost two frames this time so obviously
much more definitive
the 6900 xt still wins the one percent
low match up though
and at 4k there's a bit more separation
between the cards with the 3090 coming
in three percent faster than the 6900 xt
and 11.3 percent faster than the 6800 xt
doom eternal is my final game and only
vulcan title and it scales really well
even at 1080p allowing the rtx 3090 to
come
very very close to 420 frames per second
the 6900 xt gets even higher though
hitting 434.4 fps which is 3.5 percent
faster
at 1440p the rtx 3090 takes back the
lead hitting 340 fps and topping the
6900 xt by 2.25 percent
and the 6800 xd by 10.7 percent and
finally at 4k
the graph looks almost boring because
all the cards are just kind of sitting
where you'd expect
3090 on top then 6900 xt then 3080 then
6800 xt
and then finally the 3070. all right
next let's talk about temps and power
draw here are the peak temperatures
recorded for each card across all tests
including the hotspot temp that radeon
cards have listed now
which is the hottest spot from an array
of sensors on the gpu die
the average temperature listed for the
amd cards is a better comparison if
you're comparing to the temperatures
shown for the nvidia cards but another
reason why i think the 6900xt is getting
better binned
chips is the max and hotspot temps are
right in the same ballpark with the 6800
xt
despite the increased performance this
is further evidenced by the power draw
results of the whole system where the
6900xt actually drew less
average and peak power than the 6800 xt
with the same settings otherwise they
are both drawing about 80 watts less
than the rtx 3090 though so amd retains
the lead in overall efficiency when the
cards are under full load
and here are my overall numbers evenly
weighted by game using the rtx 3070 as
the 100
baseline remember that at 1920x1080 the
tests often become cpu limited which is
why there's more of a difference at 1440
and 4k
but just reminding you again the rtx
3070 is a pretty good equivalent for the
rtx 2080 ti
which cost well over 1200 bucks just a
couple months ago and now we have four
gpus available that consistently
outperform it
by a good margin a lot of the time and
three of those four cost a thousand
dollars or less a thousand dollars is
still
a lot of money but it's great to see
that amd can even afford a ticket to
this dance
i decided to do my pricing chart just a
little differently this time around
basically i just took those relative
performance numbers and divided them by
the theoretical price of the card
i think this has advantages over cost
per frame calculations
because if you add up all the average
frame rates then do maternal at 400 fps
will have much more of an impact than
say flight simulator at 40
or 50 fps everything is still relative
to the rtx 3070 though which means that
yes
at 500 the rtx 3070 is at the top of the
pack
in price to performance among this group
with the 6800 xt just a notch or two
behind
at 4k and 1440. the flagship cards
suffer a lot due to their top end prices
in this comparison
the rtx 3090 more so at fifteen hundred
dollars
but also an indication of how much the
price bump to a thousand dollars over
hurts the 6900 xt in terms of value so
here we are at the end of 2020 and let's
answer that top level question who makes
the fastest graphics card in the world
uh well that is still in video with the
1500 rtx 3090 but
who makes the best bang for the buck
graphics card at the high end of the gpu
market
there i think you can make a strong
argument for the 1000
rx 6900 xt and that in and of itself is
a big leap forward for amd's radeon
technologies group considering that a
couple months ago the answer to that
question was
well there's no competition at the high
end of the gpu market so nvidia can
pretty much charge whatever they think
people will pay
hence the rtx 2080 ti price the 6900 xt
comfortably outperforms the rtx 3080
and comes within striking range of the
rtx 3090 which is what amd needed it to
do in my opinion
nvidia will continue to flaunt their rtx
features and ray tracing performance and
not without reason they do have
a significant lead in that area but it's
up to you whether or not you think ray
tracing should be a significant factor
in your buying decision
it will depend on the games you want to
play and if they support those features
speaking of buying decisions though you
probably don't need to make that call
anytime soon as all indications are that
amd's stock of 6000 series gpus is even
worse off than nvidia's 30 series
inventory so
patience will be required for anyone
interested in one of these cards and i
wish you luck if you're seriously on the
hunt to find a new graphics card amd
or nvidia right now but that is all the
time i have for this video you guys
check the description before you go i'll
put links to these video cards if i can
find them and there's other important
stuff down there too like a link to my
store at paul's hardware dot net where
you can buy merchandise shirts
pint glasses and other thumbscrew
related items there is a december sale
going on right now and of course if you
enjoyed this video then hit the like
button on your way out
and subscribe to my channel if you're
not subscribed already we'll see you
guys in the next video
[Music]
you